Hi, Dave.
Hi, Sally. What are you doing here?
I am waiting for my dad.
Are you? I have to wait for my dad to come here, too.
What about going out for lunch, Kate?
Oh, I can't. I have to wait for James to call me at home.
How about ordering some pizza?
Umm, I don't like pizza and Janice doesn't like it, either.
Grandpa loves to fish and I love to fish.
Grandpa goes fishing and I go fishing.
Grandpa gets the worm and I get the fishing pole.
Grandpa gets his pole ready and I get my pole ready.
Grandpa puts a worm on my hook and on his hook.
Grandpa and I toss the worms and hooks into the water.
Grandpa and I wait and wait for the fish to bite.
Yes! A fish bites my hook and I pull the fish in.